He has achieved legendary status among conmen
by pulling off some of the most outrageous,
brazen and unbelievable deceits in the history
of fraud.
By the age of 21, he had impersonated a Pan
Am pilot, a paediatric supervising doctor
and a lawyer, charming everyone he met and
bouncing checks all over the world.
In this week’s Biographics, we take a look
at the incredible story of Frank William Abagnale.
Early Life
Frank William Abagnale was born on April 27th,
1948 in New Rochelle, New York.
Named after his father, who owned a stationery
business, Frank was the third of four children.
His mother, Paulette, was of French-Algerian
extraction.
The couple met while Frank, Sr. was on active
service in Algiers during World War 2.
They were soon married despite a thirteen
-year age gap.
Frank, Sr. proved to be a very successful
businessman with the stationery store doing
exceptionally well.
As a result, the family lived in a large home
and, although the Abagnale’s were by no
means rich, Frank.
Jr and his siblings had a comfortable childhood.
A Family Torn Apart
Frank attended Ioana Catholic School in Westchester,
New York.
His world was turned upside down in 1960,
when his parents separated.
This came as a shock to all the children,
who thought that their mother was a contented
housewife who had everything she ever wanted.
However, Frank Sr. was very active in local
body politics, as well as being active in
the management of the New York Yacht Club.
In addition, he was a very keen deep-sea fisherman.
All of these interests meant that he was often
away from home.
One day he came home from an overseas marlin
fishing adventure to find that his wife and
four kids had moved out.
Frank Sr. was crushed by the separation.
He deeply loved his wife and fought to get
her back until the day he died.
But Paulette’s mind was made.
As a sign of independence, she enrolled in
dental college and began building a life of
her own.
Frank Sr. recruited Jr. to help him win back
Paulette’s affections.
He would give his son gifts to pass on, schooling
him just to what to say and how to say it.
But Paulette wouldn’t budge.
The couple divorced when Frank was fourteen.
Living with Dad
Unlike his siblings, Frank chose to live with
his father.
This opened up a whole new world for the teenager,
who had been used to a regimented and disciplined
life with his mother.
Tagging along with his dad, he began spending
time in the bars around New York as Frank
Sr. wheeled and dealed amongst the city’s
businessmen and politicians.
The experience quickly made the boy street-wise.
It was around this time that Frank began to
skip school in order to run with a handful
of local punks who were, like him, from dysfunctional
families and seeking some way to express their
frustrations.
Frank was bigger and more mature looking than
his associates, which was handy when it to
came to playing hooky – he was often mistaken
for a teacher on an outing with students.
The group committed minor crimes like sneaking
into movie theaters and stealing candy.
Frank soon became frustrated at the childishness
and lack of sophistication of his partners
in crime.
They didn’t exhibit any of the class that
he had realized was the key to making it as
a successful criminal.
Things came to a head when his mates stole
a car while the owner was watering his lawn.
They swung by to pick Frank up only to be
stopped by the police moments later.
Frank and his fellow cons were thrown into
juvenile detention.
Frank Sr’s political connections managed
to get his son sprung and to have any mention
of the incident erased from the record.
Frank’s dad told him that he was wasting
his time hanging around kids who were clearly
not as mature or sophisticated as him.
It was time to start acting like a man.
The pep talk seemed to do the trick and Frank
began attending school regularly.
He also got a part time job as a shipping
clerk at a warehouse in Bronxville.
To show his support for his son’s change
of direction, Frank Sr. bought him his first
car – an old Ford.
Wheels and Girls
Having a set of wheels opened up new horizons
for young Frank.
Specifically, it allowed him to meet and enjoy
the company of girls.
For the next couple of years, by his own admission,
he was consumed with satisfying his teenage
libido.
He would cruise around town, prowling for
a young lady that he could entice with his
ever-growing charm into an evening of intimate
activity.
Frank soon discovered that his sexual excursions
cost money.
Invariably he’d have to supply his conquest
with a coke and a burger in order to keep
her happy.
The problem was that his meagre finances didn’t
allow for such an expense.
Frank approached his dad and requested a gas
charge card.
He promised that he wouldn’t abuse the privilege
and his father was impressed with his sincerity.
He handed his Mobil card over to his son.
A month later, Frank enacted his first scam.
Pulling into a Mobil gas station he saw a
sign announcing that you can put a new set
of tires on your car and charge it to your
Mobil Card.
It was then that he realized that you could
use the card for other things aside from gas.
Thinking fast, he approached an attendant
at the station that he was familiar with.
Frank asked what it would cost for a new sets
of tires – the answer was $160.
Frank readily acknowledged that he didn’t
need new tires but said that he was desperately
short of cash.
So, he suggested that he buy the set of tires
and charge them to the card.
But rather than taking the tires, the attendant
would give Frank a hundred dollars for them.
He could then sell off the tires for $160,
making a quick sixty-dollar profit.
Ten minutes later Frank drove away from the
Mobil with a hundred dollars cash in his pocket.
He was hooked.
Over the next few weeks, Frank replicated
the scheme at different Mobil stations around
the Bronx.
At times he would simplify the deal, offering
the pump attendant to give him ten dollars
of cash while signing a bill for a twenty-dollar
gas sale.
It was only when the bill from Mobil arrived
that Frank realized that his father was the
chump who would pay for his excesses.
But Frank had a simple solution- he threw
the bills into the waste bin.
Of course, that didn’t solve anything.
Pretty soon, a Mobil representative visited
Frank Sr. at his store and requested an explanation
for an outstanding $3,400 bill in 3 months
after 15 years of impeccable payment history.
Frank Jr. was called in front of both men
to explain.
He said he didn’t know what they were talking
about, but neither man was convinced.
Finally, Frank admitted it, but quickly offered
the ultimate excuse . . .
It’s the girl’s dad – they do funny
things to me.
I can’t explain it.
His father nodded with a wry smile and replied
. . .
Don’t worry about it, boy.
Einstein couldn’t understand it either.
Unfortunately for young Frank, his mother
wasn’t so understanding.
She blamed his criminal activity on the influence
of his father and promptly organized for him
to attend a Catholic private school for problem
children.
Frank spent a year there.
During those twelve months his father’s
financial fortunes took a steep reverse and
he lost almost everything.
He was quick to assure his son that the $3,400
that he had stolen was not a factor in his
money problems.
On His Own
Frank left home at 16.
He left without saying a word to anyone, hopping
on a train to New York City.
Along with the few belongings that he’d
crammed into a suitcase, he had in his possession
a check book that had $200 in the account.
An hour off the train he had attached himself
to a teenage boy and convinced him to take
him home with him.
Frank went on to spin a story about being
an orphan and that he was determined to make
it on his own in the big city.
The parents offered for him a stay to as long
as he wanted it.
The next day Frank got a job as a stock clerk
for $1.50 per hour.
He quickly found out this was not going to
pay his way in New York.
He figured that the reason for his low wage
was his age.
So, he simply altered the date of birth on
his driver’s license from 1948 to 1938.
Now, as a 26-year-old, he went out looking
for another job.
He found one as a truck driver’ helper for
$2.75 an hour.
Frank supplemented his income by cashing checks
from his account.
After a couple of days, he knew that his account
was overdrawn, but that technicality didn’t
phase him.
He continued writing bad checks on a daily
basis.
It didn’t take him long to rationalise that
his time working for $2.75 an hour was not
worth his effort.
So, he quit and simply wrote more bad checks.
Pilot
One day, while walking along 42nd Street,
Frank was stopped in his tracks at the sight
of an aircrew from Eastern Airlines emerging
from the Commodore Hotel.
He was mesmerized as the captain, co-pilot,
flight engineer and four stewardesses breezed
by.
Frank wrote in his memoir that he had never
seen such a splendid group of people.
His mind began to work overtime.
Imagine if he were a pilot.
He would have instant respect – and, as
a result, would be able to cash checks anywhere
with impunity.
Continuing down the street, he found himself
outside of the Pan Am building.
Quickly he formulated a plan.
He returned to his accommodation, found Pam
Am’s phone number, rang and asked to speak
to someone in the purchasing department.
He went on to inform the purchasing officer
that he was a Pam Am pilot based in Los Angeles.
He was due to hop a flight back home at 8
pm, but his uniform had been stolen.
He confidently requested a replacement uniform.
The helpful purchasing officer gave Frank
directions to the uniform company to pick
up his uniform.
He walked out with a complete co-pilot’s
uniform in hand.
What he needed now was a pilot’s ID card.
He quickly had one made up, affixing the Pan
Am logo from a model plane that he purchased
for $2.49.
Decked out in his Pan Am uniform, Frank walked
into La Guardia airport.
He was soon approached by a TWA co-pilot who
asked what Pan Am was doing at La Guardia.
It turned out that Pan Am did not fly out
of La Guardia.
Picking up on his research, Frank replied
. . .
‘oh, I just deadheaded in from Frisco on
the first flight I could catch.
I’ll catch a chopper to Kennedy’
This answer seemed to satisfy.
But then the co-pilot asked . . .
What kind of equipment you on?
This threw Frank.
In his research, he hadn’t come across the
word equipment used in that context.
Searching for the right answer, he came out
with . . .
General Electric.
The pilot was actually asking what type of
plane Frank flew so the quizzical look on
his face at this reply was understandable.
Frank quickly made his departure.
He didn’t attempt to board a plane that
first day.
He was to spend some weeks getting confident
in his role as he wandered the airport, struck
up conversations with pilots and built his
store of ‘shop knowledge’.
During this time, he also found great success
in cashing checks in his pilot’s uniform.
In fact, the tellers couldn’t give him the
cash fast enough.
Finally ready to take to the skies, Frank
turned up at La Guardia’s Eastern Operations
office and informed the desk clerk that he
needed to deadhead to Miami on the next flight,
assuming that there was room on the plane.
Deadheading was the name used for the practice
of allowing staff to travel for free in order
to get to a job location.
He was told there was a vacancy on a flight
departing in fifteen minutes.
Within minutes he found himself in the cockpit
sitting in a tiny seat which came down from
the door behind him.
With him were the pilot, co-pilot and flight
attendant.
After asking what type of equipment he flew,
the three pretty much ignored him for the
rest of the flight.
Before getting off at Miami, Frank made a
date with one the stewardesses who was laying
over in Miami that night.
Amazed at how simple the whole process had
been, Frank became a serial deadheader.
Upon arriving in a city, he would stay overnight
in a motel used by Pam Am staff, charge the
bill to the company, and in the morning, before
heading to his next deadhead flight, cash
a bad check for a hundred or more dollars
just to have some ready cash.
This pattern continued for two years, between
the ages of sixteen and eighteen, taking him
to twenty-six countries on more than 250 flights
that covered in excess of a million miles.
Doctor
By the middle of 1966, Frank was ready for
a new gig.
He had experienced a close call when someone
had stated that he didn’t actually work
for Pan Am.
Fortunately, his bluster and feigned outrage
got him through the challenge but he knew
that eventually the game would be up.
It was when applying for a long-term lease
on an apartment in Atlanta, Georgia that he,
on a whim, wrote down his profession as medical
doctor.
When asked what type of doctor he was, he
replied that he was a paediatrician, based
in California but was on a 12-month sabbatical
to audit some research papers.
Things went well for a period of time, until
one day he got a knock at the door.
His new neighbor introduced himself – Dr.
Willis Granger, chief resident paediatrician
at the Smithers General Hospital in Marietta.
Frank was afraid that Granger would blow his
cover but, fortunately the real doctor wasn’t
one to talk shop and they were able to cross
each other’s paths without incident.
Meanwhile Frank spent as much time as he could
at the local library reading up on the subject
of paediatrics.
A few weeks later Frank felt confident enough
to accept an offer from Dr. Granger to tour
Smithers General Hospital.
After that he made regular visits.
On one such occasion he was approached by
the hospital administrator and asked to do
him a huge favor – could he cover a midnight
to eight shift for a doctor who would be away
for ten days due to a death in the family?
Frank objected that he didn’t have a licence
to practice in Georgia.
But the administrator countered that he wouldn’t
really be doing anything during the night
shift, just overseeing interns and nurses.
So long as he passed an interview panel of
five doctors everything would be fine.
Frank’s initial impulse was to refuse – there
were too many dangers involved.
But he was so intrigued with the challenge.
And so he agreed.
Much to Frank’s relief, the interview was
light hearted and non-inquisitorial.
He was now a night shift paediatric supervising
doctor with 8 interns and 40 nurses under
his control.
In order to make it through, Frank took on
the persona of rule-breaking anti-establishment
practitioner in the mold of Hawkeye Pierce
on his favorite TV show, MASH.
Things went smoothly until he was called to
the emergency room.
He took his time getting there, hoping that
an intern would step in.
When he finally arrived, there were three
interns gathered around the patient.
Frank asked them for their diagnoses, and
when all three agreed he told then to go ahead
with the procedure.
At the end of his ten-day stint, Frank was
approached by the administrator and informed
that the doctor he was replacing was not coming
back.
Could he possibly stay on until a replacement
could be found?
He ended up spending 11 months as a doctor
at Smithers Hospital.
Lawyer
After finishing up at the hospital, Frank
decided to leave Atlanta.
He moved to Baton Rouge, Louisiana where he
met up with a flight steward that he had formerly
had a relationship with.
Remembering that Frank had told her about
his (supposed) law degree from Harvard, the
girl introduced him at a party to assistant
state’s attorney, Jason Wilcox.
On learning that Frank was currently out of
work, Wilcox told him that the Attorney General
was looking for bright articulate young lawyers.
Why didn’t he take the bar exam and practice
with them?
Once again, Frank found it impossible to resist
the challenge.
On his third attempt he passed the bar exam.
He was given a position in one of the Attorney
General’s civil departments.
The job was really that of a glorified errand
boy, but Frank was happy in the anonymity
of the role.
Around this time, he began dating a girl named
Gloria, who was a staunch Methodist.
Through this relationship he ended up on a
church committee, sitting alongside a man
who was a real graduate of Harvard Law School.
This guy began asking too many specific questions
and Frank knew it was time to pull the plug
on his law career.
Frank next turned up in Utah, where he claims
to have scammed his way to becoming a teacher
at Brigham Young University for eight months.
However, the university denies that he ever
worked there.
Prisoner
By now Frank was wanted in many parts of the
world for a long list of fraudulent activities.
The FBI were on his trail, as was Interpol.
His luck finally ran out while he was spending
time in the southern French town of Montrichard.
He was arrested on the basis of an Interpol
warrant for fraud issued from Sweden for fraudulent
checks written during a visit while he was
supposedly a Pan Am employee.
The French authorities soon discovered that
he had written false checks all over their
country also and so they refuse to honor the
extradition.
Frank was sentenced to 12 months imprisonment
in France, which, after being reduced to 6
months, was served at Perpignan prison.
Conditions were abysmal and Frank’s weight
went from 198 to 109 pounds during his stay
there.
He was then extradited to Sweden where he
served another six months imprisonment.
Upon his release from Malmo prison in Sweden,
Frank was taken into custody by US Federal
officers and returned to the United States.
After a third trial, he was convicted to twelve
years imprisonment for multiple cases of fraud.
During his time in US custody he escaped twice
but was recaptured on both occasions.
Going Straight
After four years jail, Frank was offered a
deal – his prison term would be quashed
if he agreed be an on-call consultant to assist
the authorities to investigate fraud cases.
Frank agreed.
After his release from prison he took on a
succession of menial jobs, only to be fired
for not revealing his criminal past.
He then decided to parlay his vast criminal
experience into a legitimate career by becoming
a security consultant and advising companies
as to how they could avoid the sorts of scams
that he had perpetrated for so long.
He went on to set up his own fraud protection
company, Abagnale and Associates.
He has been advising the FBI on fraud related
matters for more than 40 years.
Frank Abagnale, aged 70 in 2018, lives in
Charleston, South Carolina, with his wife
Kelly.
They have three sons, one of whom works for
the FBI.